Nancy mace really stepped in it because
she showed up to the National Prayer
Breakfast and decided to open her
remarks with a joke about how she almost
fornicated before showing up to the
event another year another standing room
only event and when I woke up this
morning at seven I was getting picked up
at 7 45. Patrick my fiance tried to pull
me by my waist over this morning in bed
and I was like no baby we don't got time
for that this morning uh I got to get to
the prayer breakfast and I got to be on
time and a little TMI but um I I know he
can wait he's got we got I'll see him
later tonight
um but I was here early today
just so cringe and this is the defining
feature of Nancy mace's political
Persona and it's
it's very sad and she should try to nip
it in the bud and a lot of other
conservatives who are tempted this way I
should nip it in the bud too it's not
the sex stuff it's that she always wants
to be the cool conservative